foreign
[Music]
ER as well as directors what was the
inspiration for the story yeah
um so I mean usually everyone's asking
me if it's autobiographical and it's not
literally something that happened to me
you know it's more like an emotional
autobiography uh in terms of the
inspiration I was writing a lot during a
period it was during one of the curved
lockdowns so just to you know not go
crazy and save a little bit of you know
the money I was spending on wine I
decided I would write more uh to
compensate for it and I was reading a
lot more as well and I was reading a
short story by the writer Lauren Groff
um where it was a
about a high school boy who falls in
love with a cadaver just for context
it's actually a really sweet lovely
authentic Melancholy you know evocation
of the teenage experience but I didn't
really like I finished it later but I
couldn't even get past like the halfway
point because in one sentence it just
says he goes to his first party this boy
in high school and suddenly like a flood
of memories to the one party I went in
high school came back at me
um and you know just like this really
Vivid sense of the the kid I was at the
time and what I thought the world was
like and how
you know I was pretty absent from myself
and for my life in high school I felt
like the teenage years were just like
the the waiting room and you know life
was gonna happen for me from University
onwards
um so I kind of like thinking about it
felt like I was reliving it a little bit
and then having glimmers of uh you know
ideas of things I was going to write one
day and I never did and eventually the
you know there was two guys were talking
in a car and all this dialogue was
flying at me and I ran it was like 2 A.M
by the way I rushed out of bed straight
onto the laptop and just kind of tried
to you know keep up
um with the words that were coming to me
and just try to type as fast as they
could and you know
um my husband woke up at 8am and he's
like what are you doing in your
underpants on the laptop and I was like
oh I've been writing and um like 65 of
the script was written in that one night
um and it turned into this basically
that's amazing
I feel like what happens in this is a
is a particularly gay thing
where
I am a particularly gay thing
I am too
um
were you sort of like
live in this isolation that you don't
really understand and then you discover
another person but always in your story
that person can't stay around right so
you just
hang around longing for them for the
longest time let's
but I'm just wondering if if it is in
particular a gay Coming of Age story I
think there is a sense that like there's
a special kind of loneliness that you
experience as a queer kid in a place
where there aren't any others and you
know I was uh so it's not my I was
openly query okay in my final year of
high school and I partly came out
because I was like someone else is gonna
you know at least secretly tell me
they're gay and I was waiting for that
and it never happened to this day
there's no one from my whole high school
that I know of who you know was you know
statistics would say this is someone but
like I never met that person they no one
like I spoke to where did you graduate
sorry what year did you graduate 2003 I
graduated
um but no there is a special kind of
Wellness when you think you are the you
know only one and you know it wasn't
um because I was pretty like you know in
myself like I never experienced the
guilt or the shame or those things I
think I was safely in denial whenever I
you know I had an internalized from a
phobia by the time I realized I was gay
I was very much out and proud to myself
but um so it was kind of I don't know a
fun thing realizing it was queer in some
way but uh there was a loneliness that
came with it and I think that that is
experienced very commonly were a lot of
queer kids especially in kind of more
kind of you know limited surroundings
um I do think that's a loneliness other
people can relate to and like the amount
of people who come to me at the end of a
screening uh crying growing how did you
know my life story who are straight
women you know like and a lot of gay men
obviously as well but so I'm really
happy about that that it can connect to
other people who aren't you know like me
on the surface but yeah I do think
a queer experience comes with a certain
kind of loneliness that it was the
driving force you know behind this and
you know um everyone's always
the other question I get how did you
make this film after you weren't be
alone which by the way is about 19th
century Macedonian which is and so like
woozy and voiceoveries if you haven't
seen it's effing amazing thank you thank
you but it's very different on the
surface but I'm like you could call this
film you won't be alone just as
comfortably and the title would fit so
yeah I think you're very much onto
something you say
so let's talk about your actors
who are also
[Applause]
effing amazing how did you find these
three
oh
um it was uh arduous the casting process
wasn't very conventional
um in the sense that the kind of very
much fit what I was looking for but it
was difficult to commit to other people
that this was it
um and uh like Alias didn't come through
until like the third or fourth short
list by which point my casting agent was
just like frantically panicking and just
throwing anyone who looks remotely like
me you know into the shortlist and I was
like that was the first time you know I
saw someone with feeling in their eyes
that you know spoke to me of life
experience that I understood that I kind
of in intensely and innately connected
with
um and he he looks nothing like what was
written technically speaking
um physically but like
and that was kind of also the thing like
I was like he has to be in the movie
somehow and I sort of was
um couldn't find another role and then I
was looking at it and going okay
envisioned the film with this face and
this eyes and this voice you know doing
the story and what do you think about
the film and I was much more interested
in that version rather than what I wrote
um with Tom Green it was different in
the sense that uh well irrespective of
the casting process I kind of dug up
like every Show reel by every male actor
in Australia under the age of like 40.
um and I came across a clip of him in
the film called
um
I'm having a Down River
um and it was I mean there was a few but
there was one that was very simple it
was just him walking into a cafe and
there was just a sense of like magnetism
you know purely as an actor but also it
felt like I was watching someone being a
person rather than trying to show me
something to someone inhabiting a
personality
um and coincidentally he had just sent
his audition tape like that hour
um because they desperately emailed my
costing agent to contact him and she's
like well here is and you know like his
first read-through was already like spot
on there was no Direction necessary and
yeah Hattie uh was in the first round
that was sharing to me I think like
several hundred girls auditioned it was
like 30 that I got to see
um and that was the only one I ever got
for callback and again it felt spot on I
didn't have as Vivid a picture
physically of what ebony would look like
I mean I think she was blonder in my
head maybe in a very big but that was
about the only difference because
essentially just like I was looking for
a voice and like a particular speed and
energy and kind of like
be someone who's really alive and yeah
um these
three are amazing because of the
intensity of their relationships in this
movie uh I'm just wondering for for each
of you can you talk about how you found
that with each other
um did you guys have a rehearsal time
very much rehearsal time together
um yeah
no
nope no we didn't rehearse a whole lot
at all
um Goron doesn't work that way
uh he likes it just to feel natural on
screen and um it generally works that
way when it's the first time performing
it
um so we'd go through the the direction
of course and understand our our
circumstances and everything but a lot
of it was just
just let the camera roll
so yeah I think Doug the first time I
met Elias we went and had a burger
didn't we yeah we had a we had a burger
yeah yeah but when it sat down had a
burger and Richmond in Melbourne and we
just talked about it
um but yeah after that it was like
coffees and just going through the
script like play-by-play
and there wasn't a lot of rehearsing
which was part from the dance that was
rehearsed yeah
but it was it's you know it's scary like
not rehearsing but at the same time
after a while you forget all about it
so but um and I think that that
intensity actually comes from that you
know because you're scared like you
are now you've scared
because that guy will just be like where
do you want to start you're like maybe
here do it roll
and you're like all right so you're
vaping trying to get that nicotine hit
beforehand you know I think it just all
helps
really well
the first moment in the chemistry read
we all just clicked
um and it just felt right when we
bounced off each other really well
um which is really important because I
think a lot of the film rests on our
chemistry with each other particularly
with these two
um so yeah I think it was just lucky and
we hung out quite a bit during
pre-production Garen took us around to
all the real life locations one day
um we're all together in a really hot
sweaty car
um so yeah we we didn't have any
rehearsals but we spent a bit I think
this is the thing I think what people
call a rehearsal like is uh to me
rehearsing is just sitting and talking
about anything like spending time
together purely connecting as people and
then you can talk about the story but
like I don't do read-throughs I guess
yeah
but to me rehearsing is sitting in a
space and talking and connecting because
the chemistry happens from that not from
like be um acting on the same lines over
and over again I feel so how did you
convey to Hattie that ebony needed to be
the worst
capital w o r s t
I said is you are the epitome of the
worse than this if I loved it sorry so
much I just told her just think you're
playing me
action
[Laughter]
it was so great as I could I could just
picture that over the years how many
times she had done this and that Cole
had to like rescue her from some place
in the suburbs of Melbourne
um
yeah they were they were so
uh specific I think each of you are so
specific I appreciated your work at just
when I watched that I'm just like
I don't understand how that's
accomplished but I assume it's because
you're really great actors and you're
really
great director who loves to work with
actors
it's not gonna go crazy
um no they're pretty good but um they're
all right no but I think the other thing
is also like them as I'm very much a
believer in kind of adjusting the
character to the actor rather than the
actors of the character not because of
like skill set or whatever like they
could do the role as written there was
no we have we have that footage
um but I I think uh when you when you
you know there's things that you can't
write or imagine in advance so when you
meet someone there's an energy or like
Essences to them that like you'd be
crazy to just go no let's do the script
um uh it's like I want to capture and
preserve that personality for what it is
in itself and then it kind of you know
measures with what's written
um and but also like they were
encouraged to improvise quite a lot and
you know not all of that made it on
screen but sometimes
the looks and gestures along the way in
between the Improv like there was a
dynamic that built out and those are the
moments you preserve but also a lot of
it is improvised but when they're like
oh they're sort of checking each other
out in the car and she's on the phone in
the background yelling at her mother she
literally invented that entire model oh
okay okay yeah that's my last question
was going to be is everything as
scripted or did you allow them to sort
of play with some improv quite a lot of
improv I think even in the finished film
right
there was actually can I just say there
was one I think one of the first days
Hattie was on set
um we hadn't actually had I hadn't had
any scenes with her
and I came on set and she was doing the
phone booth scene and um I was behind
the screen watching and then I think it
was the second take and I was listening
and it was completely different and I
grabbed Christine and I was like is this
I'm looking at the sides and I'm like
this isn't what's she doing she's like
she's improvising the entire thing
so you're going
all right was this the car she makes to
the mom
or the cause
like the opening sequence uh if you put
Hattie in a phone booth magic comes out
I thrive
we had to teach her how you use a phone
because she was born in 2002 I believe I
was gonna say yeah there was a lot that
was confronting you guys someone born in
2007. this is a few generations of
people that don't know how to use a dial
phone now or
handset phone or recognize the
references that you've written into the
film because they're from the 90s which
is before they were born
that was mostly the direction yeah
I'm wondering for the three of you
um did you relate to the story
in the script when you were there things
in it
that Did you sort of feel like it was a
universal story as well that we were
talking about the love story in it
with my character in particular I did
relate to a lot of the vulnerability I
was a fairly shy kid as in in school so
um yeah I played to that quite well I
think but yeah that's that's how I was
able to
draw I mean I definitely have never read
boar has or Kafka I tried to actually
I actually did try
um and I feel like I'm calling that
sense I tried I had no idea what's going
on but the
um I definitely felt the the you know
the scene where they have to say goodbye
to each other I've been through that
um twice
so that really like struck a chord
um big time
yeah
yeah I was really merged by the script
the first time I read it
um I think the themes are so Universal
um
you know kind of First Love and right
person wrong time and
wanting to escape like the place you
grow up in
um so I related to all of that stuff and
then with ebony
hopefully I didn't relate too much to
her she's a bit of a cow
um but I've I've I've met multiple
people like her you know growing up like
she just lived in me through observation
um
what I really loved though is that I
believed you in Cole's relationship when
he said
you know when when you say I think you
need to get away from ebony
he's like no I love her
and I believed him and I believe that
that you loved him as well so that's
what I loved about it this was it was
genuine
love on their part
so your your tagline says
all we have is now
um
but you know at the end called saying he
he basically
like time stopped on the day that that
he met Adam and he felt like he
hasn't Advanced and he isn't living in
the moment anymore
um was that always your choice was the
so is your choice for the ending in
um what are your 50 do any of you sort
of have feelings around what's next
for coal
um yeah the ending was always what's
written um pretty much we shot the first
draft there was very little variation so
in terms of everything that happens it's
quite close to what it conceived
um
oh you know taglines are things that fit
on a person or really don't like it when
you summarize a film in just words
because I never find I mean when I have
to do it because I never feel you know I
think if it's something that you can
phrase in words you should write a book
I think a movie needs to be a feeling
that you can kind of communicate through
it being a movie or nothing else
um but in a literal sense
um
I guess it does connect to
like I said like part part of writing
the movie was about like
because it didn't live in the moment you
know um growing up I thought life
happens where Wonka Y is you know or
where Birdman is or Catherine Hepburn
you know it didn't happen in Mcleod High
and going back to it was like me trying
to live in the present tense uh because
I didn't back in the day and yeah there
is a sense of what we have is now and
you know as much as I was trying to
relive it and like it was a beautiful
experience and it helped me a lot as
well and I really cherish it but there's
always going to be that regret uh in me
of like I wish I was more present in in
the present tense back in the day and
I've learned to be more present now as a
result yeah
any feelings about is is coal going to
remain stuck in time is it going to
unstick himself
I haven't really thought about it I
don't think I want to tell people I
can't keep it a secret
yeah I don't actually think I've
considered it either
I think when we're shooting it like you
may have fleeting thoughts about it but
never want to hang on to those
you know I kind of like walking away
from it and just sort of letting it air
um
and hopefully like in the audience
watching it it should feel that way too
I kind of like that
several people have begged me not to
make a sequel which I'm just like
flattered than anyone assumes someone
would throw money at me to make a sequel
in terms you know it's like me not
making a movie is a favor amazing
um but I I do think I appreciate that
sense so I I think it would record if if
we kind of destroy that ambiguity of
that ending because I I mean I I
definitely see it in a very concrete way
and I have a feeling what's going to
happen next other people have a
different version
um and I think that's something really
special and I don't really want to let
go of it
um because when I was writing it
originally I did have a sense of uh
you know the Antoine twinell or the
before films of like revisiting these
characters every 10 years because I love
them deeply and I love these kids you
know the real live versions deeply as
well but I I think every time I I
thought I'd rather just write a
different script than they could be in I
think it's
it's I would love it if people are dying
to find out what happens next but I
prefer people to want more rather than
less than what you've shown them so I'd
keep it to that I like the ending I
liked it that it left me thinking about
things a lot that's the kind of meaning
that I like
so this comes out when
the 17th of February 17th Friday and
please tell everybody what's next what's
next for each of you
I just finished editing the third one
um so we're doing sound mix when I fly
her uh next week wow yeah yeah I haven't
slept in two years
um after that I have no idea I might
have a lot of spare time if anyone's got
any jobs going so apart from looking for
reps over here I'm just auditioning
I'm going back to a full-time retail job
same
back in Melbourne
I've taught him to put in a good word
for me as well actually
unemployment
that's it well I think we're doing a
sequel
[Laughter]
um y'all are incredibly fabulous in this
and thank you for collaborating
collaborating this is one of already one
of my favorite films of this year so
thank you so much thank you thank you
for coming to talk to us
see thank you
thanks everyone
[Music]